today on the matt walsh show the
pro-abortion leftist death cult
continues to melt down in spasms of
demonic rage over the texas abortion law
we'll talk about that also a new report
says that half of the nation's children
are overweight or obese i wonder if
keeping them cooped up inside for a year
and a half could have something to do
with that and the bachelor contestant
canceled a few months ago for uh going
to an old south themed frat party has
hit the interview circuit for her
apology tour and it's incredibly
embarrassing to watch as you might
expect plus fast food restaurants are so
desperate for workers that they're now
advertising openings for 14 and 15 year
olds some people are upset about this
apparently but i think it's a good thing
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matt wall show
i got a question for you should viagra
really cost 90 not that i know how much
it costs
i don't think so that's why i've got to
tell you about rex md rexmd.com has fda
approved generic viagra starting at just
two dollars per tablet and delivered
discreetly to your door here's how it
works just fill out a brief survey and
if appropriate you can try a starter
pack of generic viagra starter packs are
currently available to uh new customers
rexmd.com has helped over 100 000 men
get generic viagra from the comfort of
your home
and uh look this is a deal that can
really get you excited there's no co-pay
there's no doctor's office visit and
your shipping is always free if you're
looking for generic viagra rexmd has
made the process fast easy and also
affordable so what that means is uh if
you're if this is what you're looking
for you don't want to wait another
minute rex md is now offering starter
packs of generic viagra for new
customers visit rexmd.com walsh right
now to get started that's rex
r-e-x-m-d dot com slash walsh
we are now on day two since the texas
law banning abortions after heartbeat is
detected went into effect um the
pro-abortion legions have certainly not
calmed down at all if anything they've
they've are growing more unhinged and
delirious in their
frothy spittle flecked rage and the rage
is all the more hysterical now because
the supreme court has officially as of
last night denied the request from the
abortion industry to put a halt to the
law with john roberts dissenting along
with the other liberals of course
the reaction from the pro-abortion death
call it kind of reminds me of if you've
seen the exorcist it reminds me of the
last scene in the exorcist when the
priest is drawing the demon out of its
host and she writhes and curses and
vomits and everything
that's what it really reminds me of if
for whatever reason you ever had any
doubts as to who the bad guys are in our
interminable culture war you need only
witness this entire scene i mean listen
to what these people are saying
and what they have been saying over the
last 48 hours watch how they've been
acting and the truth should be very
plain to you
now it may seem simplistic to some
people when you talk about good guys
versus bad guys
and maybe one half of that equation is
kind of simplistic i mean i know myself
and my own flawed nature too well to
give myself the label of good guy
perhaps a guy who is
trying pathetically to be good
might better fit the bill but the bad
guy line is more clearly drawn i think
the fact is that one side in this
ideological struggle
has overseen facilitated funded and
committed
the serial slaughter of 60 million human
beings in less than half a century and
it's not enough for them their bloodlust
has not been satisfied they want to see
another 60 million killed and another 60
million and on and on
any attempt to stop the extermination or
even slightly slow it down
is met with anger so intense and
irrational and
shamelessly wicked that the only
description that fits
in describing it is demonic
i mean that's the fact of the matter
the these are the bad guys
these are always the bad guys because
all throughout history
you know there have always been people
pointing to other groups of people and
saying that those people are not real
people and don't deserve to be treated
as real people and the ones doing the
pointing
are always the bad guys always history
shows us that but i don't need to wait
until this chapter is in the history
books to see who is who and to call
these people what they are and that's
why when i see all this panicking over
uh over the abortion law from the
pro-abortion pro-abortion side
and i hear them screaming
and i hear them say oh no they're coming
for our abortion rights
i could only respond yes you're right
we are coming for your abortion rights
we want to burn the whole industry down
and leave it in ashes we want to dance
around the smoldering rubble
while you cry
that's what we want to do and and you're
right also
that the tide is turning against you
see we in the pro-life movement are
actually stronger today than we've been
in years
and you notice that and it scares you
and it should
i'm happy that we scare you
i'm happy that you're so angry and upset
it makes me very happy
because we speak for the children that
you want to slaughter we give voice to
the ones that you want to silence
and we're being heard
we will be heard
your pathetic trembling fear is
delicious i love it because it means the
bad guys are suffering a defeat
that they very richly deserve
now there are many examples we could
examine here of the bad guys
you know reacting to this defeat
we could look for instance at dr derrick
cass who put out a frantic threat of
tweets urgently recommending that women
in texas get on birth control
immediately
which of course
admits that abortion is used as a form
of birth control she's saying well if we
can't have abortion then make sure
you're on the birth control pill
if we can't have that form of birth
control
the murderous form then uh then make
sure you're using contraception
this has always been obvious that it's a
form of birth control but the left
rarely admits to it as explicitly and
loudly as they have been over the last
uh few days and then she writes this she
also writes if you find out you're
pregnant and do not want to be
you have very little time to do it do
not shut down this will be hard but you
can't delay call me we'll figure this
out together
that's that's very nice and inspiring
yes call me and we'll figure out
together how to execute your child
but that pales a comparison i think to
uh this there's another string of tweets
this is from richard hananiah who's the
president of some kind of research
institute and a newsweek contributor
and he wrote this uh this morning he
said you can't screen for down syndrome
before about 10 weeks and something like
80 of down syndrome fetuses are aborted
if red states ban abortion we could see
a world where they have five times as
many children with down syndrome and
similar numbers of other disabilities
uh could could be outliers in the whole
developed world there are already
negative stereotypes of americans in
those states one can imagine if getting
much more it getting much more extreme
what if they also ban genetic
engineering and embryo selection while
other places go
ahead can it get any more clarifying
than that
he is openly criticizing the law on the
basis that it will allow more down
syndrome people to exist
he even says that the existence of down
syndrome people will perpetuate negative
stereotypes
about red states i guess the negative
stereotype in this case is that red
states don't believe in eugenics
now over on cable news cnn and msnbc the
reaction has been just as twisted and
frantic there are many clips i could
play for you but i'm going to play just
one um this isn't uh there isn't a lot
of emotional hysteria in this clip but
it's interesting only because of who is
speaking on the issue watch this
here we are on september 1st the first
day
since 1973
when a state has been able to ban
abortion 1973 as the year of roe v wade
and
the supreme court has said nothing they
have allowed the second most famous
opinion of the last hundred years after
brown v board of education to
essentially
be violated be of be overrun
but
they haven't even said a word about it
which strikes me as a real blow against
the supreme court's institutional
reputation
it's the uh
it's a famous opinion you know what else
was a famous opinion dred scott
that was a famous opinion
uh
that was established precedent at one
time
but yeah that was jeffrey toobin by the
way who is worried about institutional
reputation now of course you know
jeffrey toobin as the guy who really
wanted his co-workers to
you know see his point during a zoom
call if you catch my drift but he's he's
a lot more than a public masturbator uh
he's got more in his resume than public
masturbation he also according to
reports tried to bribe his mistress to
abort his love child
and when she refused he tried to avoid
paying child support and she had to
bring him to court to get him to pay
so this sad masturbating adulterous
deadbeat
lump of lard is the guy that cnn brought
on to analyze the texas abortion law
talk about shameless
but that's actually pretty appropriate i
think tubin who by the way should be
legally required to keep both hands
visible during tv hits uh is is a
perfect representative of abortion
proponents generally and especially male
abortion proponents
and they're always the ones who who get
to me the most
maybe just because i'm a man myself
these are the most pathetic specimens on
earth i believe
because it's a man's calling it's his
vocation to protect and defend the
innocent especially his own family
but these men would rather kill than
fulfill that obligation
and it's worse than that even because
they're not the ones doing it you know
they're not doing the deed themselves
they turn the other way and let their
wives or girlfriends or mister says
carry the physical and emotional burden
they say okay go ahead and uh my child
could be killed and tossed in a dumpster
you can live with guilt for the rest of
your days
if it means that my lifestyle's
protected it's all worth it
and even the men who support abortion
and yet have not had any of their own
children executed still support it so
that they might preserve that option for
themselves should they need it in the
future so these are not men at all in my
view
these are more like miserable
slimy little lizards scurrying around
is that too harsh i don't think so i
mean i have nothing but contempt for men
who will not do
what they are meant to do as men you
know a man is supposed to say to the
mother of his child i am here i will
always be here i will give my life to
you and the child a man who says instead
this child must give his life for me
so that i won't be inconvenienced is
again no man at all not worthy of the
name
and this is what's so deeply disturbing
one of the things about abortion it's
that this is such an inversion of the
parental instinct
parents are supposed to sacrifice for
their children not the other way around
one of the greatest examples of this by
the way and i was thinking about this
yesterday
um thinking about sort of like the
opposite of the tubans of the world one
of the greatest examples of how the
parent-child relationship is supposed to
work was given to us by a guy named
thomas vanderwood he's a name you
probably don't know
and he died several years ago and the
manner of his death is is horrifying and
yet beautiful at the same time
because one sunday afternoon
his youngest son who has down syndrome
someone who shouldn't exist according to
the guy earlier
as young as someone was out in the yard
he fell through a broken cap on a septic
tank
and into the sewage below and tom ran
over jumped into the sewage and was
trying to pull his son i couldn't
couldn't pull him out so he submerged
himself in the sewage so that he could
lift his son up above it with his body
and uh by the time help arrived a few
minutes later
tom was dead his son survived
now
see that's a man that's a that's a
that's a parent that's a father
that's someone who's last act on earth
was to give his life for his child he
plunged into
filth and died horrifically
just so that his son could live
now tom was already a great man before
he performed this final act it might not
be fair to measure anyone up against him
but even so you put
him up against the tubins of the world
the men and women who hyperventilate
over any attempt to restrict their
ability to murder their own kids and
they just shrivel into nothingness it
becomes very clear which is the ideal
which path is right which example we
ought to follow
we aren't all going to be martyrs or
heroes of course but we should be
required to fulfill at least our most
basic obligation to our children
and that is that's what the whole debate
is really about more than anything
the question is
i think this is the primary question in
the abortion debate
even before we get to personhood or any
of these other these other really
fundamental questions which is not
really a question at all because it's
clear that the child is a person but the
first question is should parents
be allowed to kill their children
instead of caring for them is murder an
acceptable parenting strategy
the answer to that question at least in
texas is as it should be no
and in the end
uh through all of this
we see why the left guards abortion so
jealously and and panics over anything
that threatens it
because for them for the people in the
death cult abortion is the holiest
sacrament because it's the final victory
of the self over everything else
for people who see no higher good than
the advancement of the self their own
self specifically not really anybody
else's self
abortion's not only necessary but it's
even a virtuous act it's the ultimate
triumph
right it's it's a person saying that
their own pleasure their own convenience
their own lifestyle is so sacrosanct
that they will spill blood to preserve
it they will sacrifice their own
children
at the altar of the self
and that's why i call it a death cult
and it's also why we should fight it
tooth and nail
to the end
now let's get to our five headlines
now a quick word from paint your life
you know we we
recently moved and still getting the
house kind of set up well i'm not
getting the house out of my wife is i i
have no sense of these things at all
but every day i walk in and you know
things more things have been assembled
and put up and decorations have been put
up and what i certainly have noticed is
that paintings can really bring the room
together and they can make your your
home feel like i'm especially a painting
of one of your loved ones if you want to
give a truly meaningful gift uh to
yourself or to someone else you've got
to try paint yourlife.com get a
professional hand painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly uh
affordable price or combine photos of
people or places that you love into one
painting you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect
it's a user-friendly platform it's easy
to make your custom order and get this
hand-painted portrait in less uh and get
it ordered anyway in less than five
minutes delivery is very fast as well
i've done this myself and we were
extremely happy with the final product
and also just how easy it was and how
hands-on they were and receptive to all
of our feedback and everything else so
at painterlife.com there's no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed and right
now it's a limited time offer get 20 off
your final painting that's right twenty
percent off and free shipping to get
this special offer text the word matt to
sixty four thousand that's matt to sixty
four thousand text matt to sixty four
thousand paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most
okay so
uh as we continue on the road here you
know i complained yesterday that i had
been put up in a serial killer hotel
which i had my room was like something
out of a horror movie filthy dark
tiny
sinister stains on the walls and bed
sheets
uh a chalk outline of a dead body on the
carpet
there was literally i'm not making this
up a raccoon curled up in the closet
and like cockroaches sitting at a table
in the corner playing poker smoking
cigarettes you turn on the faucet and
blood comes out um i think i might be
blending the actual room with the
nightmare i had about the room while i
was sleeping in the room but you know
you get the idea anyway because of my
diva meltdown yesterday on the air today
i've been put up in a luxury suite
downtown and i have to say
i'm still offended and i'm repulsed by
this room first of all only one of the
bathrooms in the room has a hot tub
which is outrageous no champagne bottles
were waiting for me when i when i showed
up here
they don't even have bathrobes if you
can believe it not that i'd actually
wear a bathrobe that a thousand naked
bodies before me have uh have been in
but i'd like to know that there's one
there hanging in the closet just uh
gives me peace of mind so
just one humiliation after another on
the trip i have i have been asked to
sacrifice so much i really feel as i sit
in this room right now
i feel connected to the people
who are in like wagon trains on the
oregon trail i think that's the best
comparison
in a lot of ways all right um
moving on so there's one other point
actually that i want to make on this uh
this texas law this abortion thing
and it's it's the point that i'm sure
you know i'm going that i can't i can't
resist making i have to make
which is that
over the last couple of days
we've seen this resurgent the the the
feminists have come forward again
the feminists who have kind of receded
into the background on the left have
fallen out of favor in many ways
um but they're now on the forefront
and they're talking about things like
women's rights and this is an attack on
women's bodies
and this is this is a handmaid's tale i
mean these are misogynists and sexists
who are supporting the slobs because
they want to control women
okay well you know what i'm going to say
what is a woman then what are you what
are you talking about i don't know who
are these people you're talking about
women what is that
i don't know what you mean
so you can't have it both ways
you got to pick one lane of crazy or the
other you can't do both here that
doesn't work
because you've been telling us for years
now that women don't exist and that men
can get pregnant
if men can get pregnant too
okay then then how is this an attack on
women
specifically
you would if it's an attack on anyone
which it isn't obviously you
damn psychopaths uh we're just trying to
stop people from being killed but if
it's an attack on anyone it's just like
it's an attack on everyone right it's
not attacking anyone specifically
i mean the texas abortion law is an
attack on me because i could get
pregnant
apparently
i've never tried don't plan on it but
that's what i'm told
so all of a sudden now we're hearing
about this
after years and years i mean especially
recently
pregnant women women's bodies like these
these phrases are not even used anymore
even by our public health authorities
and official documents they won't talk
about pregnant women and now
so that they can play the identity
politics card
now they uh the lgbt and everyone higher
up on the victimhood ladder
temporarily they have stepped back and
allowed the feminists to climb that
ladder again
just surely out of political convenience
if this is an attack on women
if this is an attempt to control women's
bodies
then that means that only women can get
pregnant
now we're starting to
now now we're starting to okay well only
women can get pregnant and now and now
the picture of what a woman is is
starting to come into focus isn't it
you gotta pick one of the other just
doesn't work i'm sorry
all right this is from the federalist it
says nearly half of the nation's
children aged 5 through 11 now qualify
as either overweight or obese according
to results of a new study out friday
researchers from the university of
southern california and the university
of michigan found the proportion
of u.s children age five between five
and eleven who are overweight and obese
on the body mass index rose from just
more than 36 percent pre-pandemic to
nearly 46 to nearly 46 percent over the
course of prolonged classroom closures
uh dr tim lodgeman says school is
essential kids are eating ultra
processed foods locked in at home and
it's making them sicker
a literature review on effective
strategies for childhood obesity
prevention published in may of last year
lends credence to lo lo jimin's claims
um
according to a team of 19 european
researchers who reviewed more than 400
studies from 2000 to january 2015
school-based programs to mitigate
childhood obesity were found far more
effective than seminars directed at
parents to teach healthy living at home
okay so there are
there are assumptions here that
that i don't agree with and one of one
of the assumptions
is that uh
parents are incapable of
preventing their children
from becoming fat
or the idea that that parents need
seminars in the first place
it's more effective than a seminar like
i don't need my children are not obese
i don't need any seminar for that
they don't they don't drink soda hardly
at all we don't have a lot of junk food
in the house
and uh they they we we they get plenty
of exercise they run around and play all
the time we're always making sure that
they're we get them off the couch
they don't have phones they don't sit
around couch all day looking at phones
limit the tv time
and all the rest of the time we say what
my parents said to me when i was a kid
and i said
i'm bored
well you can go outside and play or you
could do some chores what do you think
those are your two options if you're
bored i'll i'll help you out i'll make
sure you're not bored anymore
so i don't need any seminars i already
know that
the idea that uh that kids need to go to
school so that they don't become
obese is absurd
but
the connection between
the lockdowns and obesity
is is pretty obvious it's not a
coincidence
that we've seen a 10
spike in childhood obesity which was
already
sky high i mean 36 percent
especially when you consider what it
takes
to be obese as a child
this should be something that we're all
used to seeing obese children walking
around and it's very sad to see but this
should be something like you almost
never see this should be seeing an obese
child should be like it should be like
you know
it it it should be like it's like
spotting a unicorn or something it
should be just something you never see
because children are you know they've
got very active metabolisms naturally
and they're very and they should be
active themselves naturally they've got
a ton of energy
it's extremely and you can control
everything they eat they're not eating
anything you don't give to them
you don't want you don't want your kid
to be obese just don't have soda in the
house
don't have junk food and and don't let
them sit on the couch all day boom done
no more obesity of children
36 is crazy 46 percent is even more
crazy 10 hike it's clearly clearly
there's a um
connection but i would say the
connection is less the fact that they're
that they weren't going to school and
more the fact that so many parents kept
their kids locked inside and at the same
time we shut down the playgrounds
let's let's never forget that
even where i lived you know they were
they were putting caution tape around
playgrounds like it's a crime scene
taking the uh the basketball hoops down
and basketball courts
taking away the opportunities for kids
and then a lot of crazy parents also
didn't want their kids going outside
they're afraid that their kid walked
down the front yard the coronavirus was
going to come and you know assault them
so
that's the connection but there very
clearly is a connection
and as we hear about
um
coronavirus among children and we we
know
that it is very rarely severe among kids
they're at much higher risk from from
the flu than they are from coven
but but there there have been some
severe reaction there are going to be
some children who react severely to
coronavirus and i'd be very curious to
know
how many of the of those kids were
overweight or obese
they're not very forthcoming with that
information but that would be an
interesting thing to know
because we know that the obese are
especially susceptible to this fire the
obese are especially susceptible so
let's shut down the parks let's shut
down the plague let's tell people they
can't go outside without a mask on makes
a lot of sense
all right next rachel kirk connell is
the uh the bachelor contestant who if
you recall she was cancelled a few
months ago
because she uh there was a
a photo that surfaced
originally on instagram
where she went to an old south themed
frat party back in
2018. why did she go to an old south
theme frat party well it could be
that she's a neo-nazi skinhead
confederate
uh you know amalgamation of of all of
the terrible things all rolled into one
and she went there to celebrate white
supremacy and racism i mean that could
be it
for this ditzy air-headed sorority girl
air-headed
yeah she's she's stupid i just called
her air-headed this air-headed person
um anyway
it could be that or or it could be that
she went to the party because she wanted
to wear the dress and take pictures yeah
that was one of those but everyone
assumed it's because it's more the
former and that she wanted to celebrate
white supremacy and racism and she's
really a nazi and so the picture came
out and she was canceled
and but she's been groveling and
apologizing this whole time
um
mostly groveling and apologizing you
know kind of in instagram post and
everything but now she's hit the
interview circuit
and she appeared on something called
from privilege to progress
on instagram live
which already sounds unbearable
but now let's watch and uh listen to
what she had to say let's listen
and i guess that's the first time my
eyes opened about okay like
this is there's a difference between
being not racist and anti-racist because
back then if you would have asked me
like are you a racist person
i would be like of course i'm not you
know like
i would never ever ever judge someone by
their skin color or
you know be prejudiced towards them or
racist towards them like that's that was
like
i would have never ever
considered myself that back then
and that was probably the first time i
realized like okay so there are layers
to this you can
obviously be overtly
openly racist but
you can also be
or have like
implicit bias and and
these
racial tendencies within you that you
don't even know about or you can be
racially ignorant
and that was probably the first time i
had
realized that and
i think the peak for me was last summer
during the movements after george floyd
that's when i realized like okay i need
to do more than just
not be racist
so there you go she's uh she's learned
that there's a difference between racism
and
anti-racism
i mean she claims that she learned this
so this was a this was a um
an epiphany that she had before the
picture came out so that's that's and
and part of the epiphany of course you
know you can see how she throws
everything in there she throws a little
kitchen sink into it
she talks about racism versus
anti-racism she's acknowledging her
privilege and then she even
talks about the martyrdom of blessed
george floyd hallowed be his name and
she says how that was the final thing
that made her confront racism
just
again continuing to grovel and apologize
and say everything that her cultural
overlords demand her to say
and
the thing is they'll sit there i mean
the people doing this interview
whoever they are you could see them kind
of
sitting there
and and you know listening and nodding
their heads and saying well it's very
good you're saying the right things
yes dance puppet
dance
uh you could see them doing that
but it's not going to change anything
she she will still be forever and always
according to these people
uh a racist scumbag that will never
change
but she will she will continue to try
she's even still apparently with the guy
was a matt jones i think
the the bachelor who they were all
competing competing for and she won the
competition i don't even know how the
bachelor works actually so i think
that's she was competing for the
affections of this guy i believe his
name was matt jones and she she won and
then this whole and then this whole
controversy started
and he he threw her under the bus to her
face on live tv called her a racist
he was tearing up and crying
claiming that he was emotionally
traumatized
because his girlfriend went to a party
and wore a pretty dress
three four years ago
and she's still with that guy too
doing her penance
hoping that eventually forgiveness will
come but it will never come
you know that's that's
forgiveness is like a two-way street
not that she has anything to be forgiven
for
but there's no on the other side there's
no willingness at all to forgive
and again to forgive a thing that there
was nothing wrong with in the first
place
yet another uh
another lesson for us all this is you
know when when
when they come for you and the cancel
mob comes from yours i always say
there's just
there's no reason to apologize it's not
even about being brave
i mean it's good if you can be brave and
have a have a backbone have a spine if
the cancel culture mob ever comes for
you and they'll come for us all
eventually
but even if you're not especially brave
there's also kind of a self-preservation
thing here
you gotta calculate risk and reward
or at least resign yourself to the
reality which is that
you're done as far as they're concerned
if you if you ever want it to be
respected or liked or or plotted
by the people in the mob it's never
going to happen now
ever
and that's that's just how it is you
might as well accept that
all right this is from business uh
insider it says a mcdonald's in medford
oregon has a banner out front
advertising that it's hiring 14 and 15
year old workers
the biddle road restaurant operator
heather coleman told insider there are
always staffing issues but this is
unheard of she said the situation is
unique in her family's 40-year history
operating mcdonald's franchises
the young workers have been a blessing
in disguise coleman said
they have the drive and work ethic
they get the technology they catch on
really quickly she says
while raising the minimum wage to 15
didn't bring in as many applicants as
she'd hoped opening the doors to 14 and
15 year olds brought in about 25 new
applications in two weeks you said
uh well what do you know we were told
it's the it's got to be 15 an hour
that's supposedly a living wage
because apparently someone is working
part-time running a cash register at
mcdonald's that's supposed to be a job
like a career that you can live off of
and they raise the minimum to uh they
raise the they do the 15
minimum wage and has no effect
people still aren't interested
um instead no why are they attracting 14
and 15 year olds one of the reasons is
that 14 and 15 year olds aren't getting
that sweet unemployment money from from
the uh from the government
and they weren't directly receiving the
stimulus checks
but for whatever reason and i say that
kind of rhetorically i know the reason
uh the reaction to this and there are
other the article goes on this is a
trend now as more and more fast food
restaurants especially are directly
advertising themselves to 14 and 15 year
olds putting banners out front saying 14
to 15 year olds we're hiring come on in
and this has been
apparently for some people controversial
they're kind of upset about this
i mean how dare you
try try to advertise to the sweet
innocent children
they should all be sitting at home on
their phones that's what they should be
doing as children
i don't see why is this controversial i
don't see why this should be
controversial
i had my first job my first i had my
first official job
working at uh it was a a snowball stand
and i think i was making like
four and a half dollars an hour or
something
i had that job when i was 13.
and i had
unofficial under the table jobs mowing
lawns before that probably like from the
age of 11 i had some kind of paying job
certainly by 14 and 15 definitely
so uh
not only is it okay for mcdonald's and
fast food restaurants to advertise to 14
and 15 year olds it's a good thing they
should be doing this
for for two reasons number one
it's good for the kids
what's the downside they're not they're
not working in a coal mine we're not
sending them down to the coal mines
they're not they're not working
you know in
in a factory in the early period of the
industrial age
where where factory accidents are
happening seven times a day and their
you know arms are getting caught in
machines and ripped off that's they're
sitting there running a cash register
pouring some salt onto fries and that's
it maybe they get a little if there's
some splash from the grease they get a
little bit burned i think they'll be
okay
so it's good for the kids it's not bad
for them it's good for them they're
learning work ethic they're earning a
little bit of their own money
uh i i could tell you for sure that as a
kid and this is there's no contest here
at all for me personally cause i went to
public school and i also had part-time
jobs
and uh where did i learn the most
in the jobs for
sure that was the best education
so you're learning not only generalized
sort of work ethic and and
how to show up on time how to fulfill
your responsibilities those are really
important lessons for kids to learn and
other lessons and also lessons that they
often don't learn in the public school
system
but they're also just some basic
skills that you're learning
running a cash register you've got to do
math at least back in those days there's
some math involved at least now it's all
now not quite as much
but um still you're kind of you're
you're applying some of the academic
things that you're learning in school in
the real world and so it's all positive
it's a great thing
it's also good for families
especially lower income families i mean
because we have this idea
that kids like you shouldn't get a job
until you're 18 or something and even
then maybe don't get a job
and so in lower income families and
really in any family
you have kids who are able-bodied they
could easily get a part-time job and do
it
and contribute to the household income
at least be able to buy some things for
themselves
be contributing members of the family
and uh but but so often they're not
because of this absurd idea that some
people have
that it's it's wrong for a teenager to
work
and then the other point also is that
these jobs are are made for teenagers
that's why the raise the minimum wage
thing
the vast majority of people aren't even
aren't on minimum wage
um that's a that's a that's a relatively
small minority of the overall working
population
and a great number of them are young and
these are jobs that are not meant to be
it's like these are not ju a minimum
wage job is not meant for
someone like myself 35 years old with
four kids at home
because even if they raise the minimum
wage
to 15 an hour that's still not really
going to be enough to fulfill all the
obligations that i have
these jobs are made for kids it's
perfect for them
because they they don't have they don't
have a family to support on their own
they don't have kids of their own
hopefully
uh they can do these kind of minimal
tasks
that are very easy to learn
and benefit in the process it's a great
thing it's a wonderful thing okay
uh let's move on now to
reading well here's this also i just
want to show you this this is a tweet
from a ford europe
it says you asked ford to make the very
gay raptor a reality and we heard you
our real-life version made its debut at
cologne pride last week in its in all of
its rainbow-adorned glory and then you
can see
uh the vehicle there
decked out in rainbows
they said that we asked for this
and that's why they did it
and they're right actually i i i have
but i how many times have i said it
myself i've been asking for this how
many times in the show have i said we
got to have the very gay raptor
so thank you for it finally
for doing that okay that was an
important note before we get to our uh
reading the comments this is from
lupin's red jacket says reminder it's
not a right if it tramples the rights of
another in this case the right to life
of which is made abundantly clear in a
constitution that it must be protected
just as just as much as any other
yeah this is where we get into you know
what is a human right and i think
almost everyone has a very vague idea of
what a human right is
that this this this goes back to
this lies at the foundation
of many of our disagreements and debates
like we can't even agree on what a right
actually is
and it is hard to define
but one thing we know for sure
is that rights actual human rights
which are inherent to our human nature
are not in conflict with another
with one another
okay so it's not a zero-sum game with
human rights
so if you get
if you find yourself
in a position where there's a tension
between two rights claims
where if if one person
is able to exercise their rights
it means that another person can't
exercise theirs
what that tells you every time is that
there's a confusion here about rights is
that
one or both
of these rights claims are not
legitimate
because when it comes to actual rights
if they're real then you should be able
to exercise them without
causing any harm to anybody else
um
okay moving on this is from
ct it says i know you'd be hard-pressed
ever side with abortion but you said
reproduction should never be forced
could it be argued then that abortion
could be allowed in the case of rape
resulting in pregnancy this argument
definitely has a lot of loopholes women
falsely claim rape you could argue that
it would only be feasible if the rapist
is convicted
but the child should would be long born
or aborted by the time the courts
determine probability just curious on
your thoughts huge fan thanks for
everything you do
uh no because again it's already
occurred right
i said that we don't
we don't force reproduction no one is
trying to do that
and yeah you could say rape is is that
but that's not a law i'm talking about
legally
there's no legal effort to force women
to reproduce
as much as we hear that claim in
relation to these abortion laws
that's that's an entirely different
thing because at the time of the
abortion the reproduction has already
occurred
uh now the rape obviously should not
have happened
it's a travesty an injustice the person
responsible should be convicted and then
uh and then as if i if if they if i had
my way they'd immediately be marched up
the gallows and hanged in front of the
whole town that's what i think we should
do with actual convicted rapists who are
guilty
but the force reproduction at that point
has already happened
and abortion can't undo that
or change it that's the point
all it can do is create one more victim
the rape should not have happened
clearly
um
but this person exists now this is a
person who exists
how do we address the rape or mitigate
it in any way
by killing that person
what you're talking about is executing
the child
for the sins of the father and
that's atrocious
um
stanley says so glad that matt isn't
just making 90 of his coverage about
afghanistan like everybody else in khan
inc yeah i you know i i said a couple
weeks ago when i did talk about
afghanistan a little bit but i started
the show
when this was first in the news um again
anyway
and
i said this is this is
i'll talk about it
but this is not my area of focus
it's not because it's not important i
mean everybody has certain areas that
they focus on and and have something to
contribute on
foreign policy is important
but it's not what i focus on i i tend to
focus on the issues that are impacting
us right here at home
and they're also the issues that i
personally find the most interesting
and i think the most about and have read
the most about and therefore feel like i
have something to contribute when it
comes to them
another comment says when you're on the
road do you apply your own makeup if so
you need to record it the sweet baby
gang would love it
um
we're not gonna talk about
what happens with the makeup we're just
not gonna discuss it
okay
we don't we don't discuss it
we especially don't discuss it
in the hotel room
the things that need to be done
in order to make sure that makeup is
applied
we don't talk about those things
um my producer sean actually applies it
that's that's that's what he's he's
learning is how to be a makeup artist
um and i know that he's quite he's quite
thrilled about that all right uh
paul says had a dream last night and
matt was in it we were at a wedding
together and he was running around and
tate and tapping all the guests and
pointing at me and yelling making fun of
my shirt then at the reception i was
eating at a booth with matt and his kids
and every time i tried to put the fork
to my mouth matt would try and throw
food into my mouth he was laughing until
the waiter asked him to stop like i said
this was my dream not sure why we were
in a booth or why i was eating waffles
but i feel like the part about matt is
accurate as foretold
uh yeah paul unfortunately i have to ban
you for the show from the show for this
because we don't we don't talk about
dream stories
dream stories are the are the the most
pointless and boring
stories you could possibly tell your
dream is interesting to you but not not
to anyone else
i i will allow it if i'm in the dream
selfishly
but even this story i mean you lost me
halfway through
and i just i completely lost interest so
you're banned even though i just i think
i talked about my own dream a few
minutes ago but
of course i don't have to abide by my
own rules and finally chloe says day one
of asking matt to shave his beard for
the lulls
well chloe day one of me telling you
that you are
obviously you knew this was coming
banned from the show for that how dare
you
well as you know once a month your
favorite daily wire hosts come together
to drink a little whiskey smoke few
cigars and have a lively conversation
about the state of the world usually
everything that's uh wrong with it and
sometimes it it devolves into a
screaming match
maybe not quite a screaming match but
but uh close to it and while every
episode is special our upcoming october
october episode is going to be a little
bit extra special instead of just tuning
in from your home
you'll be able to see us live and on
stage at the famous ryman auditorium
right here in nashville doing what we do
best making sense so join myself ben
shapiro candace owens jeremy boring
michael knowles and andrew clavin for a
backstage like never before we have a
very special offer for our members
starting at 11 a.m eastern today daily
wire members get first dibs to buy your
tickets ahead of general admissions so
check your email for an exclusive
uh code that you can use to pre-order
your tickets once you have your code
pre-purchase your tickets ahead of
everybody else at dailywire.com
ryman and if you're not a member then
you can join today at dailywire.com
subscribe to get your choice of seats or
wait until tickets go on sale everywhere
tomorrow friday september 3rd so check
your email to make sure you don't miss
out now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we're
gonna cancel uh weddings
not all weddings you know not the
sacrament of matrimony certainly i'm a
big fan of matrimony so such a big fan
that that i'm going to try something
different and only do it once
if you're really a fan of it that's what
you do um i think more people should get
married uh when i'm theocratic dictator
of the hemisphere you'll be required to
get married before the age of 25 or
become a monk or a nun
but these are the kinds of policies that
nobody in washington has the guts to
propose the point is i think marriage is
great which means
that weddings are great nowadays great
they're they're sacred they're mystical
they're transcendent what i'm canceling
instead are the many elaborate and
self-centered forms that modern weddings
have taken i'm canceling especially
the dreaded destination weddings those
are cancelled
and what brings this to mind is a recent
story in the new york post about a
couple that decided like so many couples
before them that their nuptials were so
special and important
that a normal wedding somewhere in the
continental united states wasn't good
enough for them they needed to travel
thousands of miles away to a foreign
land
and when guests didn't show up this
couple sent those truant guests a bill
so here's the report it says the
honeymoon's over for a pair of newlyweds
who were so steaming mad at wedding
no-shows who originally rsvp'd yes
that they slapped them with a 240 bill
to cover their costs
a now viral photo of the invoice tickled
twitter this week
uh calling out the no show no call
guests and declaring i don't think i've
ever seen a wedding reception invoice
before the bold move which is sure to
seal the fate of that friendship sparked
a heated online debate over whether the
couple's missive was tacky or totally
justified the no shows were given a
payment due date of one month from
august 18th invoice sent by the once
anonymous newlyweds whose um
resort and spa wedding in jamaica
apparently cost 120 ahead
per the detailed invoice that many
tweeters assumed was fake turns out it
was not fake the post tracked down the
offenders doug simmons and deidre mcgee
now simmons doug apparently was so proud
of himself for this stunt that he posted
the bill to his own facebook
and the invoice said according to what
he posted on facebook this invoice is
being sent to you because you confirmed
seats at the wedding reception during
the final head count because you didn't
call or give us proper notice that you
wouldn't be in attendance this amount is
what you owe us
for paying for your seats in advance
you can pay via zell or paypal please
reach out to us and let us know which
method of payment works for you thank
you
and the article continues and says when
reached by the post the groom admitted
that yes he got a little bit petty but
i'm not some trifling person who's going
to bill somebody even though it's
exactly what he did uh simmons a small
business owner in chicago stressed that
it's not about money he and his new
bride were merely hurt and felt
disrespected by the no-shows at their
hard-earned dream wedding with more than
100 attendees
he said quote four times we asked are
you available to come can you make it
and they kept saying yes we had to pay
in advance for jamaica this was a
destination wedding okay
let me explain what happened here doug
first of all
nobody on your guest list
actually wanted to go
none of them did
okay if they wanted to spend money and
vacation time on a trip to jamaica
which most of them didn't
but if they did want to
then they just would they'd go on a
vacation they'd prefer to do it on their
own time to enjoy the trip for
themselves
and not have all of these assignments
that they have once they get there
you're not providing anyone an
opportunity to go to jamaica unless
you're paying for
all of the airfare and all the lodging
and everything for everyone which i
assume you didn't so this is not an
opportunity anybody can go to jamaica
whenever they want it's that it's that
but if that's how they want to spend
their time and money they can do it on
their own
this rather was an assignment that you
were giving them
the invitation itself was already a bill
it was here's all this money that i'm
asking you to spend for us
here's how it goes down once those
destination wedding blackmail letters go
out a certain portion of your friends
and family
who would like to celebrate your wedding
with you will have to immediately say no
because they simply don't have the time
and money to go to some far-flung
tropical location you will have
automatically excluded all friends and
family who cannot afford an extravagance
trip
and what's more you make them feel
guilty
because of your own profligate behavior
and next a certain portion will get to
get the you know the invitation and
they'll roll their eyes and they'll show
the invitation to their spouse and
they'll say oh man can you believe this
jamaica come on
but they'll still end up coming at great
financial hardship to themselves out of
this sense of obligation then another
portion will agree because they feel
forced into it but they're going to pull
out at the last moment because
something's come up in their lives that
prevents them from going to jamaica or
maybe simply because they ultimately
decide that they don't want to do it and
they resent the fact that you put them
in this position to begin with and
that's the way it breaks down and the
common thread here
is is that is that you are imposing
yourself
on your loved ones and expecting they
will cancel their own summer vacation
plans and dedicate that time to
celebrating you instead this is all your
fault
not only do your guests not owe you any
money but you in fact owe all of them a
refund and an apology for having a
destination wedding now of course not
all egotistical self-seeking destination
wedding couples would go so far as to
send you know a bill to the no shows but
they are all still egotistical and
self-seeking and we shouldn't limit this
just to destination wags
because for years the trend has been for
engaged couples to treat their weddings
as if they're royal monarchs right
weddings have become exorbitantly
expensive unnecessarily extravagant
centered more and more around
the the egos of the individuals getting
married rather than a respect and
reverence for the sanctity of the
sacrament that's being performed now
it's not that wedding shouldn't be fun
it's that they should be
they ought to be joyous and festive
but our approach to weddings often sucks
the joy and festivity out of it
you know the whole bridezilla stereotype
comes from the fact
that brides so often in our culture
feel that their big day is licensed to
be miserable and demanding and
self-absorbed i mean how did it get to
this point
it's no coincidence
that weddings are a 50 billion a year
industry in a country where divorce is
rampant
it may seem kind of like an irony that
we that we make such a big deal out of
weddings but care so little about
marriage but really it's not ironic at
all it makes sense to see things kind of
shake out this way lavish and excessive
weddings are lavish and excessive
because the people involved are
inordinate inordinately focused on
themselves and people who are
inordinately focused on themselves
usually do not succeed in relationships
especially not romantic relationships
a person who feels themselves entitled
to a day or several days obsessively
dedicated to a celebration of the self
no matter the cost and no matter the
toll it takes on their families and
friends usually they've arrived at this
conclusion
because they believe that every other
day of their lives should be the same
they think that every day is a
celebration of themselves
this is generally not a good way to
start a marriage with this kind of
costly
overwrought tribute to your own ego
especially if you don't even have the
decency to hold this carnival of vanity
somewhere within the country where you
all you and all of your loved ones
actually live
and for that reason
destination weddings are cancelled you
have to make other plans because i've
canceled all of those weddings
try renting a pavilion you know at your
local park for 45 bucks
grill some burgers some hot dogs
get a few kegs
your guests will have a blast blast i
guarantee that is the type of wedding
celebration and reception i am now
assigning to the entire world it has
been decreed
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day everyone godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audios mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
the supreme court permits a wonderful
pro-life law in texas to go into effect
joe rogan contracts and recovers from
the wuflu and a new poll shows that most
americans want joe biden to resign check
it out on the michael knoll show
you